[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es eine
besondere Torte wir machen eine
Yogurette Torte denn es gibt was zu
feiern da komme ich gleich noch drauf
zurück heute filmt der Hamza daher kann
es sein dass wir uns ein bisschen über
diese Neuheit unterhalten das ist
nämlich echt was besonderes und ich
fange direkt an mit der Zubereitung hier
meines Bodens denn die Torte besteht aus
einem schönen rührboden der ganz ganz
schnell und einfach geht und
los und die ganz genauen Mengen ganz
schön wie immer unten in der
[Gelächter]
in der Infobox genau das daher ist das
Video nicht so lang atmest und ihr könnt
direkt einen Screenshot machen und
direkt drauf los einkaufen und Backen so
da gebe ich jetzt hier noch Zucker zu
den Eiern eine Prise Salz denn die
unterstreicht noch mal den süßen
Geschmack so und jetzt habe ich hier
mein Timer schon auf 3 Minuten gestellt
und das ganze werde ich jetzt 3 Minuten
lang richtig schön dick cremig schlagen
[Musik]
die Masse ist jetzt richtig schön
voluminös und dick cremig ich habe nur
noch ganz kurz Sonnenblumenöl eingerührt
und jetzt geht's weiter mit den
trockenen Zutaten da brauchen wir nur
Mehl Backkakao und Backpulver das gebe
ich hier einmal in mein Sieb und im Sieb
verrühre ich das nur noch ganz groß
einfach damit es sich besser verbindet
und dann kommt das auch schon mit zur
dickschaumigen Eiermasse wird nur noch
so kurz genug wenn ich untergerührt und
dann ist der Teig auch schon fertig und
kann gebacken werden das ist ein
bodenwechsel gebacken hast ja so aber
ein einfacher Boden
genommen der eh schon besteht vom Video
oder so ich wollte diesmal kein basic
Rezept verlinken sondern ein Boden neu
kreieren und halt auch einen schnellen
Boden kreieren
[Musik]
zu den Tortenring habe ich vorbereitet
auf 22 cm Durchmesser in Backpapier
eingeschlagen und auf mein Lochblech
gelegt der Backofen ist auch schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze da braucht der Boden jetzt
nein 38 bis 40 Minuten ich habe den
gestern Abend schon mal vorgebacken aber
wollte euch ja das Rezept unbedingt
zeigen das sind relativ flüssiger Teig
daher auch den tortenringen Backpapier
einschlagen ja bitte guck mal es gibt ja
Leute die haben dann anrufen vielleicht
zeigen
sehr gute Frage haben Sie also aufgrund
der aufgrund der Stäbchenprobe man sagt
immer wenn ein Kuchen backt dann sollte
man den Backofen niemals öffnen das ist
mit Todsünde und man kann aber gegen
Ende der Backzeit das ist nicht schlimm
das sitzt alles da ist größtenteils
schon gab aber man kann nach 38 Minuten
die Stäbchenprobe machen können wir
gleich mal zeigen und schauen ob was
hängen bleibt bei Brownies darf immer
was hängen bleiben bei solchen Torten
würden nicht und dann kann man ja
gegebenenfalls noch 2 Minuten dranhängen
Frage beantwortet das war ausführlich
und jetzt gehe ich zum Backofen und dann
machen wir weiter tschüss
[Musik]
während unser Boden jetzt vor sich den
back kümmern wir uns um unsere
fruchteinlage es ist jetzt gerade keine
Erdbeersaison daher nehme ich
tiefgekühlte Erdbeeren die werden
nämlich erntefrisch tiefgefroren und die
gebe ich jetzt hier in meinen Topf der
mich ein bisschen antauen lassen
aber wir können ja mal kurz also ich
gebe jetzt noch Zucker ein bisschen
Wasser dazu wir können mal kurz darüber
sprechen wie kommen eigentlich dazu eine
Yogurette Torte zu machen weil wir eine
Yogurette Füllung haben wir haben etwas
erschaffen dass wir logarité schmeckt
nur als Creme ich kann noch Wasser dazu
also eigentlich eigentlich bist ja alle
worum es geht weil warum haben die
meisten das ja auch schon zu Hause wir
haben eine neue cream in der cream
Family und unsere strawberry cream und
sie schmeckt wirklich wie Yogurette aufs
Boot sehr schön oder viele haben sie
schon sie war relativ aber jetzt ist die
Nachlieferung da und deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht mach direkt ein Rezept Video
oder damit als Info natürlich könnt ihr
euch auch aufs Brot geben das ist ja
auch kein Problem aber die meisten sind
bestimmt wieder fürs Backen gemacht
zeigen ich püriere das ganze jetzt mal
und dann zeige ich euch wie wir das Fest
bekommen ohne Gelatine
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir erstmal Erdbeerpüree und
das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie fest
bekommen weil das werden unsere
fruchteinlagen in den Zwischenschichten
und dafür könnt ihr entweder Gelatine
nehmen oder agar-aga ihr kennt ja Agar
Agar von mir als agentine in flüssiger
Form ich habe es jetzt zufällig nur noch
als Blatt Variante da Blatt ich glaube
das haben die wenigstens zu Hause aber
ihr könnt auch die Pulver Version nehmen
es ist komplett alles ähm der gleiche
Vorgang nur die Mengen ändern sich die
schreibe ich euch in die Infobox ich
werde das ganze jetzt erstmal erwärmen
und dann die Blätter reingeben die
schmelzen dann und dann sobald das ganze
köchelt zwei Minuten lang köcheln lassen
und dabei steht dich umrühren das ganze
geht auch mit ähm Rinder Gelatine z.B
die habe ich ja auch schon seit Jahren
im Shop das ist so eine Gelatine aber
trotzdem wollen viele einfach keine
ja tierische Gelatine in den in der
Torte genommen mit dem Pulver also
pulverformen ist jetzt das gleiche als
auch zwei Minuten sprudeln kochen das
ist das gleiche wie diese Blatt agentine
es gibt halt verschiedene verstanden man
kann das vorher irgendwie in Wasser
auflösen und dann dazu rühren und so
weiter also es sind ganz viele
verschiedene Varianten aber ich zeige
euch die einfachste
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir natürlich das heiße
Fruchtpüree einmal umfüllen und dafür
nehme ich zwei tiefe Teller achtet nur
darauf dass die ein bisschen kleiner
sind als der Durchmesser eures
Tortenrings so als 22 cm das gebe ich
ein bisschen backtrennspray drauf damit
einfach die Folie gleich besser hält
denn ich gebe da jetzt noch
Frischhaltefolie dazu ähm damit man
schön stürzen kann nachher und dadurch
dass wir ja die Argentino benutzt haben
das ist übrigens pflanzliches
Geliermittel in Form von alten aber man
riecht und schmeckt die eigentlich da
dürft euch keine Sorgen machen so aber
da fehlt doch schon der Ofen ich will
das jetzt einfach nur kurz um und gibt
das in den Kühlschrank ihr könnt auch
ins Gefrierfach geben und dann braucht
es ungefähr eine halbe Stunde zum
abkühlen
[Musik]
so jetzt bereiten wir die Tortenfüllung
zu das sind unsere Yogurette Creme und
dafür habe ich hier einmal eine Schüssel
wo ich kalte Schlagsahne rein gebe das
schlage ich dann gleich schön steif
zusammen mit Sahnefest also Sahnefest
erst während des
schlagprozesses dazugeben damit es schön
steif wird so und in meiner zweiten
Schüssel verrühre ich die restlichen
Zutaten da habe ich hier einmal
Mascarpone das ist immer cool wenn
Mascarpone die schmeckt so relativ
neutral da kann man immer gut mit
Spielen mit dem Geschmack dann habe ich
hier noch einen Anteil Quark da habe ich
heute 20 % liegen wir können noch
Magerquark nehmen oder 40 %. da tut sich
nichts bei diesem Rezept aber ich fand
so ein bisschen fettiger jetzt einfach
leckere nice du hast echt richtig
richtig aber aber was kaputt ist
wirklich ne Mascarpone kannst du richtig
mitspielen weil das so relativ neutral
schmeckt spielen
das die strawberry cream zum Einsatz ich
muss sagen es ist so krass ne also wir
machen ja nicht so eine strawberry cream
und sagen welche Süßigkeit gibt es denn
jetzt die nach Erdbeer schmeckt ah ja
das schmeckt nach die schmeckt nach
Yogurette sondern wir entwickeln sie und
dann probieren wir das was uns gut
schmeckt und denken dann irgendwie
irgendwie erinnert die uns echt
angerührte und das gleiche hatten wir
damit der Kokoscreme Hansa Haselnuss ja
aber der Hase sagen viele bueno ich bin
persönlich eher Giotto weil das halt
super intensiv schmeckt aber die
Kokoscreme das ist die innere Füllung
vom Raffaello die hat sogar die leichte
Mandelnote im Abgang also wir haben da
echt alles gedacht so da gebe ich jetzt
einfach die oh das sieht so elegant aus
die Farbe ne das ist die cream einfach
mit dazu
moderner geworden
für die süße noch ein bisschen
Puderzucker
und dann schlage ich erstmal die Sahne
schön fest dann ruhig das nur kurz
vielleicht so 10 Sekunden mehr auch
nicht und genau dann vereinen wir wieder
alles miteinander
[Musik]
sind aber eher witziger dass der Klocke
hier auch ja danke dann übrigens auch
fürs sagen
nee
das ist immer so wenn ich mit dir reden
irgendwas ist
also ich habe jetzt folgendes gemacht
ich habe hier noch ein kleines bisschen
Lebensmittelfarbe hinzu wo ihr habt ja
gesehen die Menge war ja fast ein Hauch
von Nichts das habe ich heute genommen
Fuchsien rot so und jetzt kommt die
Sahne mit dem Teigschaber unter die
Mascarpone Masse am besten in zwei bis
drei Schritten immer schön sorgfältig
unterheben so also so sieht's auch
irgendwie cool das ist jetzt zum Marvel
Effekt aber ich rühre es komplett unter
nicht Marvel du bist ne auf jeden Fall
ist die Creme dann auch schon fertig und
wir können alles zusammensetzen in der
Zwischenzeit sind die Frucht Einlagen
auch schon fest geworden der Boden ist
abgekühlt also müssen wir nur noch
zusammensetzen
[Musik]
den abgekühlten Tortenboden jetzt vom
Tortenring entfernt ich nehme jetzt hier
noch einen backformlöser damit ich mir
die Seiten nicht wegreiße und dann teile
ich den Boden zweimal durch so dass ich
drei Böden erhalte der ist nämlich hier
gut hochgegangen ca 6 cm hoch nicht ganz
also wird jeder Boden so ungefähr 1,8 cm
hoch werden so
und dann wird auch schon geschichtet
nehmt euch eine hübsche Tortenplatte und
ich finde das immer so der spaßigste
Teil das Schichten das wird ja eine
naked cake und daher brauchen wir jetzt
dafür auch nicht so viel Zeit
[Musik]
so wir starten natürlich mit dem Boden
und der ist kann man das hören
dich wieder drauflegen und sitzen und
schlafen
Deutschland
mit der rosentülle reingelegt jetzt
dient das gleich nur zur Optik aber ein
bisschen
diese diese Spritztülle mit diesen Gold
mit der boah
auf jeden Fall gebe ich jetzt hier
einfach so ein bisschen Creme nur drauf
ganz wenig einfach damit es so ein
bisschen Halt gibt für die Fruchtfüllung
und die könnte jetzt hier ganz leicht
stürzen das ist so easy Leute so einfach
umgedreht da drauf legen zack dann
einmal Folie entfernen und fertig und
jetzt zusehen dass es optisch natürlich
hübsch macht von außen weil das ist ja
naked cake ich versuche jetzt außen
einfach so ein bisschen dass man die
Form der Tülle sieht so ein bisschen so
Spritzen
genau und innen ist egal
angekommen seid dekorieren wir nur noch
mit Yogurette und restlicher Creme
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt noch die strawberry
cream bei 600 Watt ca 20 Sekunden in die
Mikrowelle gegeben ohne Deckel ganz
wichtig und dann einfach so als
Abschlussklausur oben drauf verstrichen
und das ganze mal für 10 Minuten im
Kühlschrank das coole ist die cream wird
dann wieder fest also man kann sie
anfassen ohne dass sie so flüssig ist
wie gerade und man kann aber später mit
dem Messer gut durchschneiden ohne dass
es wie bei einer Schokoglasur knackt
oder sowas und jetzt habe ich hier noch
meinen 12er Einteiler das mache ich mir
jetzt einfach nur zur Hilfe damit ich
dann ein bisschen die Striche habe damit
ich weiß wo ich jetzt die restliche
Creme auf Spritze und dann mache ich
einfach Häppchen und dann kommen
natürlich noch Joghurette zum Einsatz
[Musik]
ja nun ein Stückchen Kaffee vor der
großen Probe ist eine gute Idee
[Gelächter]
also einmal ganz kurz einmal ganz kurz
appreciaten wie genial diese Schichten
Aussehen ich finde das sieht so hübsch
aus
ich glaube die hatten gesagt hey
durch die Gegend geschmissen hast
richtig geil aus also diese Sack ich
muss sagen ich habe einen Vorteil ich
habe mich an den Vorteil ergötzt du
weißt es noch nicht machen
so richtig gut geschmeckt um noch mal
die Creme hat man noch mal so richtig
intensiv halt diesen strawberry cream
Geschmack aber
ja generell so ich finde der Boden in
Verbindung mit der Creme die doch
relativ fluffig ist der Boden ist auch
super fluffig und dazwischen diese
fruchteinander finde ich nun mega
Kombination mega Kombi
Creme genau
trotzdem ist die süße noch also es ist
ich bin ja schon so jemand der ich bin
ich auch ich finde das ist eigentlich
genau richtig ja jetzt ist genau
Essen zusammen essen das stimmt ich
finde es richtig unfassbar durch die
einzelnen Schichten durchzuziehen
durch 12 geteilt aber eigentlich passt
es schon ein riesenstück eigentlich kann
man den also finde ich persönlich die
Hälfte kann man entweder 24 kleine
Stücke oder man macht so 16 mittelgroße
Stücke draußen
und macht nur eine Schicht
ja also sorry
also ich wünsche euch viel Freude beim
Nachmachen und ähm
ach am Ende habe ich noch Gefrierschrank
gegeben
so ich wünsche euch viel Freude beim
Nachbacken und lassen wir eure Fotos zu
kommen auf Instagram dort reposte ich
immer alle ganz fleißig und dann sehen
wir uns auch beim nächsten Video tschüss
[Musik]